Ми часто думаємо: бідні люди, в яких рак.
Але чомусь завжди переконані, що
нас така хвороба ніколи не торкнеться.
Особливо в дитячому віці – це як ляпас,
і спочатку ти взагалі не розумієш, що це означає.
Коли вона захворіла, їй було лише 12 років.
І на моїх очах через хворобу вона
дуже-дуже швидко подорослішала.
Зрештою, в неї справді вкрадені роки дитинства.
Для Катаріни та її матері щотижневі походи
до лікаря вже давно стали буденністю.
Свого лікаря, доктора Зееґера,
Катаріна бачить частіше, ніж учителів.
Він лікує дівчину вже 7 років відтоді,
як їй поставили перший діагноз.
Її остання хіміотерапія завершилася
кілька тижнів тому. Стан дівчини
потроху покращується, утім, все ще відчутний страх,
що хвороба може знову повернутися.
Вона отримує відновлюючі медикаменти,
які покращують настрій та апетит.
Вона більше  радіє життю і
наважується бути активнішою.
Хвороба дуже зблизила доньку та матір.
Вони навчилися жити з раком.
У кожній ситуації, навіть коли було дуже погано,
ми завжди знаходили, з чого посміятися.
Іноді це був чорний гумор, який зрозуміє не кожен,
а лише такі ж онкохворі, як я.
Терапія музикою допомагає розслабитися.
Хоча Катаріні довелося залишити школу і вона
не може займатися спортом, її денний графік
заповнений лікарняними процедурами.
На майбутнє я хочу, звісно, бути здоровою,
знову ходити до школи, отримати атестат і вивчати
щось гарне, медицину чи щось інше, і просто мати
банальне, так би мовити, життя.